how can we find the prime factors of any
number let's see
let's say we need to find the factors of
the number 60 so you heard we write the
number 60 and we see if it is divisible
by the lowest prime number yes it is
divisible by 2 2 multiplied by 30 is 60
now 30 is also divisible by 2 so 2
multiplied by 15 is 30 is 15 divisible
by 2 no but it's divisible by the next
prime number 3. it's 3 multiplied by 5
and we can see that 5 is not divisible
by any other prime number so we can
write 60 as 2 times 2 times 3 times 5
now because we have 2 2 0 we can write
it as 2 squared multiplied by 3
multiplied by 5. so this is the prime
factorization of 60. so how many prime
factors does 60 have
yes 4 and how many unique prime factors
three the three unique prime factors are
2 3 and 5.
using the same concept can you tell me
the unique prime factors of 42